merci
[Musique]
étrangère
tout d'abord c'est vraiment un grand
plaisir et un honneur d'être ici avec vous j'ai
entendu parler de votre programme et ainsi de suite très
populaire donc c'est génial d'être à Paris une
de mes villes préférées au monde
euh je suis  a Je suis économiste
Je suis né à Istanbul en Turquie ma
famille est une famille juive d'Iran quand nous aurons
un an Istanbul je suis retourné
à Téhéran
à l'âge de trois ans nous avons déménagé à Tel Aviv
en Israël
et à l'âge  sur quatre, nous avons déménagé à
Milan en Italie où nous nous sommes installés et j'ai
grandi là-bas, j'y
suis allé à l'école, j'ai fait mes
études universitaires, mon premier diplôme à l'
université de Bocona, puis
en 1983, je suis venu aux
États-Unis pour mon doctorat
en économie
à l'université de Harvard,
puis  J'ai été professeur à l'
Université de Yale pendant sept ans,
puis en 1995, j'ai déménagé à l'Université de New York.
Depuis, je suis professeur,
mais à un moment donné, j'ai également commencé à
m'impliquer dans la politique économique. J'ai passé
deux ans à Washington, à la
Maison Blanche.  puis au ministère du Trésor américain
lorsque Clinton était président,
puis je suis retourné au monde universitaire, mais j'ai ensuite
commencé quelques cabinets de conseil économique
vers 2004-2005 et je suppose que je suis
surtout connu pour être l'une des rares
économies à avoir prédit la
crise financière mondiale.  de 2007 à 2009,
à ce moment-là, j'ai reçu son surnom de Dr
Doom, ils sont toujours présents aujourd'hui et
j'ai travaillé en tant que
conférencier en tant qu'universitaire en tant que
conseiller économique, je dirigeais des cabinets de conseil économique en
écrivant des livres, mon dernier vient de
paraître dans  France
Mega menaces 10 tendances dangereuses qui
impérialisent notre avenir et comment y survivre
et je passe maintenant plus de la moitié de mon
temps à voyager à travers le monde, ce qui
a du sens dans le sens de ce monde très
compliqué et instable et certain,
je vous en supplie parce que nous  J'ai
quelques problèmes techniques avec la
technique de traduction mais c'est de ma faute
désolé pour le verrouillage de l'aide au déplacement à chaque
fois
étranger
[Musique]
eh bien, c'est une très bonne et importante
question
Je pense qu'il y a quelque chose dans l'
humanité à essayer de
évitez de faire face à la réalité
euh évitez de vous inquiéter des choses qui
peuvent mal tourner parce que si vous vous en inquiétez,
vous devez vous préparer, vous
devez agir, ces actions sont
coûteuses en termes de temps, d'argent et d'efforts
et les gens
vivent dans l'espoir que quelque chose de bien  va se
produire, peut-être qu'une
Force comme Dieu va venir
les sauver de leurs ennuis ou qu'un
leader va venir et faire en sorte que
les bonnes politiques évitent la
crise et ainsi de suite, il y a une
révolution technologique ou une sorte de
chance  cela va les empêcher,
donc nous avons tendance à donner un coup de pied autant que possible
sur la route,
parfois lorsqu'il y a une menace, nous
nous mettons la tête dans le sable comme des autruches
essayant d'éviter les problèmes
et chaque fois que des gens comme moi mettent en garde contre
les risques de queue
soit ils vous rejettent en disant que vous êtes un
Docteur Doom ou votre Cassandra,
soit quand j'envoie l'alarme, vous savez qu'ils
vivent comme des zombies, ils veulent se
rendormir alors ils appuient sur ce bouton de répétition,
puis l'alarme répète à nouveau le
bouton, puis de cette façon  vous faites
un somnambulisme jusqu'à ne pas être conscient de ce qui
se passe et finalement vous vous endormez
dans un désastre
euh
politique
perception super réelle domination
[Musique]
euh eh bien, je dirais que cela dépend bien sûr
des politiciens,
certains d'entre eux sont plus conscients de ces
menaces,
certains d'entre eux  ignorez-les,
qu'ils en soient conscients ou non,
les hommes politiques des pays démocrates doivent
être réélus
et donc,
par exemple, parmi toutes ces menaces dont
j'ai parlé dans mon livre,
chacune d'entre elles a des solutions mais
cette solution implique des coûts et des
sacrifices.  un court terme pour un bénéfice
qui ne vient qu'à moyen long
terme
et si vous faites quelque chose d'impopulaire le
risque est que vous n'allez pas être
réélu
je vais vous donner un exemple vous connaissez un
ancien conseiller de Germany Shredder il
était social-démocrate, il a fait des réformes pour
rendre le marché du travail plus flexible et
c'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles l'Allemagne
est devenue compétitive, mais il a ensuite perdu les
élections parce que ces réformes étaient
très impopulaires
ou prenez un autre exemple plus récent
en ce moment, le président de Franz Macron
est  proposer une réforme des retraites qui est
très impopulaire et populaire parmi la
gauche, les travailleurs, les syndicats, l'
Organisation de la Jeunesse. Je suis populaire à droite
parmi Le Pen et les autres électeurs et c'est un
dilemme
parce que s'il l'adopte, il sera impopulaire peut-être
par un décret ou par un  En alliance avec les
forces républicaines, vous pourriez avoir une
manifestation massive, cela pourrait devenir encore plus
impopulaire et les chances qu'un
stylo soit réellement élu
en 2027 augmentent
de l'autre côté s'il ne met pas en œuvre la
réforme que les gens diront bien
agi.  vous sur une campagne ou une proposition de
réforme, qu'avez-vous fait pendant toutes ces
années
et peut-être devient-il impopulaire à cause de
cela et peut-être que celui qui
représentera son parti ou ses
forces modèles pourrait encore perdre en 2027.
même dans les non-démocraties, je  je pense que c'est
difficile
euh les gens disent que les gènes autocratiques peuvent
faire des choix difficiles, ce n'est pas vraiment le
cas parce que même dans des régimes autocratiques
comme la Chine, vous devez être sensible à l'
opinion populaire
un deux vous devez prendre des décisions difficiles
impliquent des coûts à court terme
trois parfois les autocrates vivent  dans une
bulle comme Poutine vivait dans une bulle, il
n'a pas réalisé les risques parce que personne ne
voulait lui dire qu'ils avaient peur de
lui et je pense que Xi Jinping
vit aussi dans une bulle où personne ne veut
dire que l'empereur n'a pas de vêtements ou nos
la politique ne fonctionne pas et donc dans
les autocraties, vous prenez aussi
des décisions terribles, vous savez à juste titre Winston
Churchill a dit un jour que la démocratie
est le pire système politique en dehors de
toutes les alternatives et c'est vrai, je
crois toujours qu'avec toutes les
difficultés de la démocratie libérale, c'est un
meilleur système de gouvernance que d'avoir
des régimes autocratiques les régimes autocratiques
font des erreurs majeures économiques sociales
parfois ils deviennent agressifs et
violents quand au niveau national vous avez un
problème vous trouvez des boucs émissaires des
menaces externes potentielles ou des
menaces inventées et souvent les dictateurs finissent par entrer
en guerre,
en effet  la junte argentine l'a fait
et bien d'autres exemples de cette
population
étrangère,
c'est intéressant parce que j'ai écrit ce
livre sur la façon dont le monde peut évoluer dans
les 10 à 20 prochaines années
et bien sûr, certaines de ces menaces sont
plus lentes,
d'autres sont plus  imminent
mais même ceux qui ressemblent davantage à
l'avenir, je peux vous donner de nombreux exemples
de la façon dont chacun de ces 10 fils se
matérialise aujourd'hui, pas dans un an, ni dans
cinq ans pour vous donner 10
exemples pour chacun de ces 10 fils
donc bien sûr, à court terme, le risque
d'inflation
appelé récession, ce que nous appelons une
stagflation, la combinaison de l'inflation
et de la récession est un matériau important
pour les États-Unis et l'Europe. Les économies avancées, le risque
que les dettes deviennent insoutenables
à mesure que la Banque centrale augmente les taux d'intérêt
est également  menaces à court terme mais pensez par
exemple
au risque de
tensions géopolitiques, au risque de guerre entre grandes
puissances
comme raison pour laquelle il ne s'agit plus d'une
guerre froide entre les États-Unis et le nombre de
puissances révisionnistes mettrait en cause l'
économie sociale
monétaire commerciale politique militaire  ordonnons
que les États-Unis, l'Europe et l'Occident créent
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale cette révision, ses
pouvoirs étant la Chine, la Russie, l'Iran, la Corée du Nord
et même le Pakistan qui sont effectivement
alliés,
mais aujourd'hui, ce n'est pas seulement une guerre froide, nous
avons déjà de l'eau chaude entre la
Russie et l'Ukraine, c'est effectivement
déjà une guerre par procuration entre nous et l'
Europe d'un côté, l'Occident et la Russie,
cette guerre pourrait dans certaines conditions
devenir non conventionnelle si Poutine a
utilisé des armes nucléaires tactiques en Ukraine
et cela pourrait également impliquer que
l'OTAN
est donc une menace qui n'est pas immédiate  Il
y a 10 ans, je passais seulement 10
jours en Israël avant de venir en Europe
et à ce stade, il est clair que l'Iran
est un État nucléaire seuil
et qu'au cours de l'année prochaine, Israël
et les États-Unis devront prendre des
décisions difficiles quant à savoir s'ils doivent ou non le faire.  frapper l'
Iran ou non dans les coûts et les avantages
de faire l'un ou l'autre,
plus le Moyen-Orient dans son ensemble est une poudrière
vous avez les tensions sunnites chiites vous
avez déjà ces guerres par procuration menant à
l'échec des États au
Liban en Syrie en Irak en Libye au
Yémen  et les choses pourraient dégénérer davantage
et bien sûr en Asie,
cette guerre froide entre nous et la Chine
devient de plus en plus froide
et le chef de la marine américaine
a fait il y a quelques mois une déclaration
à la une du Financial Time
disant que les chances que la Chine puisse
envahir Taiwan sont élevés dans pas cinq ou dix
ans, il a dit à ce moment-là que cela
pourrait arriver avant
2024. c'était en octobre de l'année dernière
bien avant 2024, cela signifie 2023, nous sommes
maintenant 2023.
maintenant, je ne prétends pas que cette guerre
entre  nous et la Chine sur le créneau de Taiwan
va se produire cette année, mais même
cette dépression géopolitique et le
risque d'une guerre entre de grandes puissances
qui d'ailleurs ont toutes une
arme nucléaire ou efficace comme l'Iran
y arrivent, c'est un risque qui est un  nouveau
risque, ils n'existaient pas.
J'ai grandi dans les années 50, 60 et 70
et je ne me suis jamais inquiété de la guerre
entre grandes puissances ou d'un hiver nucléaire
parce que
Nixon est allé en Chine,
il y a eu un conflit entre les États-Unis et l'
Union soviétique
et le risque d'un  la guerre nucléaire entre
ces rivaux qui possédaient l'arme nucléaire
est devenue très faible, non nulle mais très faible
aujourd'hui pour la première fois depuis longtemps,
nous devons nous inquiéter de la guerre entre les grandes
puissances et les récompenses conventionnelles
deviendraient automatiquement
non conventionnelles lorsque vous commenceriez à les tuer.
d'autres, voire des choses qui ressemblent à des
pandémies de changement climatique mondial à moyen et long terme
ou à une guerre entre grandes puissances ou à l'impact, par
exemple, de l'intelligence artificielle, de la robotique
et de l'automatisation, ces choses se
produisent déjà aujourd'hui même si bien sûr,
par rapport à l'inflation et à la stagflation,
il y a plus de trains au ralenti  détruit
[Musique]
l'immigration étrangère
étrangère
[Musique] les
politiciens à différents degrés sont
conscients du problème,
le problème est que même si nous nous inquiétons tous
du changement climatique, c'est l'un des
plus grands risques car il pourrait
littéralement détruire  la planète dans les prochaines
décennies,
trouver une solution est difficile
pour de nombreuses et différentes raisons, il y en a
plusieurs ou pourquoi nous ne
faisons pas ce qu'il faut,
vous savez, raison numéro un
dans de nombreux pays, à commencer par les
États-Unis, une partie de la
population ne le fait pas  Je crois même au
changement climatique provoqué par l'homme, donc aux États-Unis,
lorsque les républicains sont au pouvoir, ils
ne font rien
et parfois ils sont au pouvoir
et ils pourraient revenir au pouvoir en 2024. Le
deuxième problème
est un conflit intergénérationnel,
vous savez, j'ai 64 ans.  si je vis encore 30
ans, j'aurai de la chance qu'un
jeune homme ou une jeune femme né aujourd'hui ait une
espérance de vie d'au moins cent
ans, il ou elle devra donc faire face
à la masse du changement climatique,
mais les jeunes n'ont pas tendance à le faire.  votez pour
les personnes âgées
et même pour les jeunes que nous avons tendance à
négliger l'avenir en espérant que peut-être
un miracle, une technologie
résoudra, alors combien de personnes sont prêtes
à changer leur mode de vie aujourd'hui, encore
plus jeunes, pour réduire leur propre
empreinte carbone si nous étions tous végétaliens
un quart de toutes les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
proviennent de l'agriculture d'élevage combien
d'entre nous sont prêts à isoler complètement
leurs maisons en installant des panneaux solaires en utilisant des
sacs réutilisables partout où nous allons combien d'entre nous avons tous des
placards remplis de vêtements
t-shirts chemises pantalons que nous connaissons partout
chacun  l'un d'eux provoque de la pollution, mais nous
achetons, nous surconsommons,
donc il y a ce conflit chez les jeunes et les
vieux ainsi que dans
trois pays à l'échelle mondiale, si un pays fait tout
le travail et les efforts pour réduire ses
émissions nettes à zéro, cela coûte très cher, mais
personne d'autre ne le fait.  Je n'obtiens aucun
avantage, les émissions sont mondiales et
vous en payez le coût,
et la coordination entre 200 pays
est très difficile. Le problème du passager clandestin,
ce qu'ils appellent
problème numéro quatre,
il y a un conflit entre les
pays pauvres et les pays riches, disent les États-Unis et
l'Europe à la Chine.  dans les marchés émergents,
réduisez vos émissions à zéro au cours des
20 prochaines années comme nous voulons le faire,
mais ils disent que
vous avez créé ce problème avec 200
ans d'histoire d'industrialisation,
quatre-vingt-dix pour cent de tout le
stock cumulé d'émissions passées, c'est vous,
c'est vrai.  que le nouveau flux actuel de nouvelles
émissions vient en grande partie de la Chine, de l'Inde
et d'autres marchés émergents, ils disent que vous
créez un problème, nous voulons que personne ne reste
pauvre, nous allons améliorer notre image pendant
encore 20 ans jusqu'à ce que nous soyons
suffisamment riches, puis nous  Nous allons résoudre
ce problème à moins que
vous ne nous accordiez des subventions suffisantes pour en payer le
coût, mais les subventions sont
estimées à au moins un billion de dollars
par an que les riches devront
transférer aux pauvres. Le Congrès américain
vient d'adopter un projet de loi selon lequel  ils donnent aux
marchés émergents 4 milliards, ce n'est que de la
petite monnaie, il vous en faut un billion, bien
sûr, aucun compte ne le fera,
problème numéro cinq, il y a
un conflit entre nous et la Chine, la
guerre froide, ils ne sont pas d'accord sur les pandémies,
ils se rejettent la faute, ils ne le sont pas.  Je ne suis pas d'accord
sur la sécurité mondiale, ils ne sont pas d'accord sur le
libre-échange, sont-ils d'accord sur la manière de gérer la
crise économique et financière et,
bien sûr, ils ne sont pas d'accord sur le
changement climatique et nous devrions le faire, etc., etc.
six
afin d'atteindre les objectifs de l'Accord de Paris,
la taxe carbone moyenne devrait être de
deux cents dollars par tonne.
Aujourd'hui, la taxe carbone moyenne est de deux
dollars par tonne. Moins aux États-Unis, un peu
plus en Europe,
quel politicien va augmenter les
taxes sur le carbone d'un facteur  de 100 de 2
à 200, personne n'est politiquement impossible
si nous faisons quelque chose dans le pays maintenant
que les prix du carburant sont élevés, les coûts de chauffage
sont élevés, tous les politiciens réduisent les
taxes sur les carburants, les taxes sur le carbone pour réduire l'
inflation pour la population,
mais si ces taxes ne sont pas élevées, ils
la transition des combustibles fossiles vers les énergies renouvelables
ne se produira pas, vous devez enfin inciter
les prix
parmi les trois solutions d'
atténuation du changement climatique. Le zéro net
implique une croissance économique négative
pour toujours
en 2020, avec la pire récession des
60 dernières années, les émissions nettes ont chuté seulement  par
neuf pour cent neuf pour cent n'est pas un autre
bien au-dessus du niveau pré-couvert,
donc
l'atténuation avec la technologie actuelle est
impossible une adaptation à la croissance négative
qui signifie que la température de la lumière ira
bien au-dessus à bien au-dessus de trois et que
vous limiterez ensuite le coût, cela vous coûtera des
milliards de dollars  d'argent, je
vous donne un exemple
depuis que New York a eu l'ouragan
Sandy et ils voulaient sérieusement
protéger l'homme après qu'il y ait eu
une proposition de construire le
mur autour de Manhattan, puis ils ont dit que ça
allait ressembler à une prison moche
maintenant ils disent qu'ils veulent  pour construire ces
digues dans l'eau la
digue est près du pont Verrazano ce
plan va coûter 125 milliards de
dollars cela va prendre 25 ans il
pourrait être obsolète au moment où vous le ferez cela
pourrait ne pas fonctionner
cela ne s'occupe que des ondes de tempête lorsque
l'eau  est debout parce que notre tempête ne fait pas
face à l'élévation permanente du niveau de la mer
et si vous protégez Manhattan,
vous allez faire flotter tout le reste.
Long Island Jersey Shore et le reste de
New York, c'est une ville l'une des
richesses du monde
et 40 personnes vivent autour des zones côtières,
donc l'atténuation est impossible, l'adaptation aux
solutions coûteuses et autres solutions de
géo-ingénierie comme jeter de la poussière dans le
ciel pour refléter la lumière du soleil est comme une
science anormale et je peux vous parler d'autres
contraintes de l'écriture, je vous donne juste
quelques exemples  c'est l'écart entre
ce que vous voulez faire en réalité c'est
pourquoi il y a tant de green washing
il y a tant de vert en souhaitant qu'il y ait
tant de feuilles vertes c'est pourquoi tant d'
investissements ESG ne sont que des conneries et
il y a du blanc il y a aussi beaucoup d'
inflation verte à faire  produire des métaux verts
qui sont nécessaires dans les voitures vertes
véhicules électriques batteries électriques lithium
cobalt cuivre zinc vous avez besoin de beaucoup d'
énergie et si le prix d'un physique est
élevé, il y a un flash vert sur le prix de la
production de métaux verts est chère et
nous ne pouvons pas les faire à moindre coût  ainsi,
ce sont les faits dont vous devez
parler, mais la plupart des gens parlent de
platitudes. Si nous faisons seulement ceci et
cela, nous faisons face au
changement climatique et ce n'est qu'une des méga
menaces qui pèsent sur chacun d'eux.  eux le large
éventail d'obstacles et de contraintes pour
faire ce qu'il faut
est
étranger étranger
[Musique]
il existe de bons médias assez sophistiqués nous
pouvons parler des risques et les signaler
et en discuter il y a d'autres qui
ne sont pas aussi qualifiés
pour le faire mais vous  Je sais que dans le cas,
par exemple, de la crise financière mondiale, vous
devez comprendre les motivations
qui ont conduit à cette bulle. Vous savez,
les propriétaires pouvaient acheter des maisons avec très
peu de valeur nette, ils pouvaient emprunter pour
leur type de maison et les
prix augmentaient, donc ils étaient
heureux,
les politiciens étaient heureux parce que
les gens qui pouvaient dépenser davantage leurs revenus
grâce à une bulle dans leurs maisons,
les banques prêtaient de l'argent, accordaient
des hypothèques
et gagnaient de l'argent avec
l'investissement.  les agences évaluaient ces titres hypothécaires
toxiques et
ils gagnaient de l'argent,
leurs louanges de la maison gagnaient de l'
argent en payant des frais
et les assureurs de ces dérivés
gagnaient également de l'argent, alors oui, la
chaîne de titrisation où tout le monde dans
cette chaîne gagnait de l'argent, les
maisons étaient  les
politiciens heureux étaient heureux que Wall Street était
heureux et tout le monde vivait dans une bulle
et une fois que vous avez livré la bulle, vous commencez
à croire quelque chose qui n'est pas possible,
que les prix de l'immobilier peuvent augmenter chaque année
20 pour toujours et ce n'est pas une bulle
jusqu'à ce que bien sûr la bulle éclate,
alors vous  Je sais que
les masses ont leurs propres illusions, le
politicien se nourrit de ces illusions et
généralement les entreprises et les
institutions financières gagnent également de l'argent avec ces
illusions, donc parfois nous vivons
dans une bulle, nous vivons dans une illusion jusqu'à ce que
la bulle éclate et que le rêve devienne un
cauchemar, alors  cela arrive encore et
encore, l'histoire de toutes les
bulles financières parle de l'illusion des
masses, des
investisseurs avides et des finances alimenteraient
la bulle et des politiciens qui en
tirent également de l'argent ou qui profitent
de ces bulles en se produisant
en série
[Musique]
[Musique] étrangère
certainement l'une des conséquences de toutes
ces
menaces et de toute cette instabilité
est le risque de
conflits sociaux
de toutes sortes pourrait être un conflit de travail
pourrait être une violence entre la droite et la gauche
pourrait être la montée de partis populistes extrémistes
d'extrême et de droite  et à gauche, il
pourrait aussi y avoir certains de ces régimes populistes et
autoritaires qui deviennent
agressifs
lorsqu'ils ont des problèmes chez eux, ils
trouvent un pseudo ennemi
et ensuite ils entrent en guerre comme la Russie l'a fait
dans le cas de l'Ukraine, donc nous
voyons certainement une augmentation des revenus et de la richesse.
l'inégalité nous voyons la classe moyenne et la
classe ouvrière se sentir coincées nous voyons la
jeune génération sentir qu'elle n'a pas
autant d'opportunités économiques que
peut-être la nouvelle génération sera plus
pauvre que ses propres parents
et tout cela conduit à une réaction violente
contre la démocratie libérale
et vous avez
des partis populistes autoritaires de droite et de gauche plus populaires vous
savez aujourd'hui vous avez
Poutine en Russie vous avez Erdogan en
Turquie vous avez Urban
en Hongrie vous avez Kazinski en Pologne
Maloney et le parti néo-fasciste sont arrivés au
pouvoir récemment en  En Italie, les
démocrates suédois faisaient partie intégrante
de la coalition au pouvoir,
même dans une Suède tolérante. En
Grande-Bretagne, vous avez le phénomène du Brexit
et tous ces populistes, puis ils ont
changé de Premier ministre trois fois en
six mois,
euh en France, nous  Il y a encore la démocratie, mais
l'un des risques est qu'en 2027, Le Pen
devienne un populiste que vous savez
au pouvoir aux États-Unis. Bien sûr, vous avez
l'élection de Donald Trump et sa
colère contre les élites et prétendre
être un populiste soucieux d'un  les
cols blancs, c'est à
droite et
à gauche, ils disent que l'Amérique latine avait l'habitude de
dire que peut-être l'Argentine, le Venezuela
était le populiste de gauche, mais regardez,
ces deux ou trois dernières années, les populistes de
gauche sont arrivés au pouvoir au Mexique et en Amérique
du Nord.  Le
Pérou, le Chili, la
Colombie, le
Brésil ont été le choix de la
population de Bolsonaro de droite et l'un
des Lula de gauche, heureusement, c'est Lula parce que
Bolsonaro est un autoritaire, ils ont juste
tenté une tentative d'écho contre Lula de la
même manière qu'il y avait un trimestre deux ans
auparavant en  les États-Unis contre leur capitale
et le plus grand autoritaire de tous, je
ne sais pas s'il est de droite ou de
gauche, c'est bien sûr Xi Jinping en
Chine qui n'est plus secrétaire
général, président de départ, il n'est pas
roi, c'est l'empereur, vous décidez
de tout  Je n'ai plus de
leadership collectif et il peut faire de
grosses erreurs comme le font les autoritaires
parce que les virages automatiques finissent par faire de grosses
erreurs, donc nous avons cette tendance partout dans
le monde
vers le populisme vers
l'autoritarisme, c'était agressif
envers d'autres rivaux en dehors de votre
pays qui mène  aussi aux
conflits sociaux au niveau national, car vous savez que les gens
sont mécontents des revenus et des
inégalités de richesse et, dans l'ensemble, de ma vie, donc oui, de
différentes manières dans différents pays,
cela peut conduire à diverses
formes de conflits sociaux, voire à une violence pure et simple,
continuons
mal, je laisse  tu redémarres ta prise tu l'
as juste sur ton épaule droite oui
tu l'as
euh
[Musique]
ok ok eh
bien il y a deux points de vue sur ce que les
banques centrales vont faire, l'
un dit que l'inflation a atteint
son pic  en baisse
et à cause de cela, ils peuvent augmenter les
taux plus lentement,
nous aurons une récession légère, courte et
superficielle, peut-être quelques trimestres
de croissance économique négative
et, avec cette récession, il y
aura suffisamment de
relâchement dans le marché du travail et des biens.  L'
inflation des prix et des salaires va baisser
donc d'ici le milieu de cette année,
la récession sera terminée, l'inflation sera plus faible
et la Banque centrale va commencer à réduire les
taux directeurs et vous allez avoir une
belle reprise de la croissance et une reprise
des aimants au second semestre.  de l'
année
donc premier semestre difficile pour l'économie
et les marchés deuxième semestre bon pour la
croissance de l'économie et les marchés c'est
la sagesse conventionnelle le point de vue des
banques centrales la plupart de vos économies vivent
votre Wall Street et la ville de Londres
J'ai un point de vue différent Voir
mon point de vue  c'est que l'inflation
va rester beaucoup plus élevée
et elle va baisser mais pas
assez vite vers 2 pour cent donc la question
n'est pas de savoir si l'inflation a atteint un sommet, elle
a atteint un sommet mais passer de 10 pour cent à
cinq six est facile, passer de cinq six à
deux.  je pense que ça va être dur les
prix des matières premières vont être élevés
Pas seulement l'énergie par d'autres pour de nombreuses
raisons cela va être inflationniste
Je pense que l'inflation des salaires va
rester élevée pour de nombreuses raisons les
marchés du travail sont tendus le chômage est
faible le
vieillissement de la population
les gens prennent leur retraite plus tôt la plus grande
démission la
réduction du
taux de participation au marché du travail de nombreuses personnes la
restriction à la migration les conflits du travail
et nos travailleurs disent que nos religions
s'effondrent nous allons faire grève nous
allons nous battre pour nos droits et les
politiques économiques du gouvernement  sommes
pro-travailleurs pro-syndicats pro-travailleurs pro
chômeurs, c'est vrai, car si vous
ne les aidez pas, il y aura un
conflit social, donc si tout un ensemble de facteurs qui
impliquent une inflation des salaires pas très élevée,
disons cinq six pour cent que  est cohérent
avec une inflation bien supérieure à 2 pour cent
et dans le secteur des services, le
coût de production le plus important est bien sûr le
travail
et donc si l'inflation du travail est élevée, l'inflation des
services va rester
élevée, donc ces
facteurs impliquent une baisse de l'inflation
mais pas vers 2 pour cent,
donc le  La BCE ne peut pas arrêter les taux seulement
à trois pour cent.
Si elle veut lutter contre l'inflation, elle
doit les pousser à quatre.
Mais si vous montez, deux choses se produisent : l'
une, vous aurez un atterrissage difficile de l'
économie réelle, plus vous augmentez les taux,
plus vous en aurez.  une récession et une
récession sont légèrement plus longues et plus
prolongées qu'une récession courte et superficielle.
Deuxièmement, à mesure que vous augmentez les taux d'intérêt,
le coût d'emprunt pour les travailleurs, les
ménages, les entreprises, le gouvernement des sociétés, le
coût des hypothèques, le coût des prêts automobiles, les
cartes de crédit, les prêts personnels, les prêts aux entreprises, les obligations d'entreprises, les
obligations d'État.
quiconque a beaucoup de dettes, les intérêts
vont augmenter
parce qu'au cours des 20 dernières années, le montant
de la dette par rapport au revenu était élevé,
mais nous avions de faibles coûts de service de la dette
parce que vous aviez des taux directeurs nuls, des
taux directeurs négatifs, ce qu'ils appellent l'
assouplissement quantitatif ou  accréditant ainsi que
les taux d'intérêt à long terme étaient bas il
y a deux ans, l'
équivalent de 18 000 milliards de dollars de dette publique
en Europe et au Japon
à des taux d'intérêt négatifs des
hypothèques négatives au Danemark à des rendements négatifs
certaines entreprises pouvaient emprunter à un
rendement négatif
parce qu'à cette époque l'inflation était  en dessous de
deux pour cent, nous luttons contre une faible inflation
avec des mesures de relance monétaire et de crédit massives
aujourd'hui, cette partie est terminée car l'inflation a
augmenté, les taux d'intérêt doivent augmenter
et ces entreprises, individus et
gouvernement, je les appelle des zombies, ce qui signifie
insolvables, ils ont trop de dettes
liées à leur  capacité de payer, ils
vont faire faillite et comme vous avez une
détresse financière
qui aggrave la récession, plus
la récession est pire et les revenus
diminuent, les revenus diminuent, alors les
ratios d'endettement deviennent plus élevés et deviennent
plus insoutenables et vous êtes plus
instable donc  vous aurez un
cercle vicieux entre la contraction économique, la
stabilité et
l'instabilité de la contraction financière, c'est pourquoi vous vous attendez non
seulement à l'inflation,
pas seulement à la récession et à la stagflation par
la crise de la dette stagflationniste, une
combinaison de tous ces problèmes
ensemble
est
[Musique] eh
bien, dans les années 1970, il y avait  deux premiers
chocs, une hausse de tous les prix
provenant de la guerre du Yom Kippour en
Israël et dans les États arabes et de l'embargo. Tous
les laissez-passer ont triplé, nous avons eu une récession de l'inflation, une stagflation, puis
en 79, vous avez eu la
révolution iranienne et un autre choc sur l'approvisionnement
en pétrole, une autre récession et une stagflation,
donc  les anticipations d'inflation sont devenues
incontrôlables, il y a eu une spirale des prix des salaires
parce que chaque fois que ces chocs
se produisaient, la réaction des banques centrales
était de ne pas augmenter suffisamment les taux d'intérêt d'une forte
inflation, elles étaient en retard sur la
courbe et l'inflation n'est devenue incontrôlable qu'en
79  que l'inflation est devenue
un tel problème que Carter a choisi comme
chef de la FED Paul Volcker et il a dit
de faire tout ce qu'il fallait pour lutter contre l'
inflation,
il a poussé les taux d'intérêt à 20 pour cent
parce que l'inflation était bien au-dessus de 10
pour cent,
ce qui a conduit à une très grave récession  en
1980-82, une récession à double creux et une fois
la récession survenue, les
salaires des travailleurs ont commencé à baisser. Les
entreprises n'avaient pas le pouvoir d'augmenter les prix
et il a pu briser les
attentes d'inflation, combattre
l'inflation et la faire baisser à un
niveau inférieur, mais cela a provoqué  beaucoup en termes de
récession très grave depuis plus de deux ans,
même si nous acceptons
maintenant,
le problème aujourd'hui est le suivant,
comme dans les années 1970, nous avons des chocs d'approvisionnement négatifs
l'impact du covid sur la production de
biens Les chaînes d'approvisionnement l'approvisionnement en main-d'œuvre l'
impact de l'invasion russe  de l'
Ukraine sur les prix des matières premières,
l'impact de la politique de convoitise zéro de la
Chine jusqu'à récemment sur les chaînes d'approvisionnement mondiales,
mais
dans les années 1970, nous avons eu de l'inflation et de
la stagflation, mais nous n'avons pas eu de
crise de la dette dans les économies avancées parce que le ratio d'endettement
privé et public était faible
de 100 %  Le PIB
d'aujourd'hui est de 420 pour cent du PIB quatre fois
plus élevé
après la crise financière mondiale, nous avons eu
un problème d'endettement,
trop de dettes des ménages, des prêts hypothécaires
et des emprunts et un atterrissage des banques,
mais nous avons eu un choc de demande et non un
choc d'offre, un resserrement du crédit, un effondrement de l'
homme impliqué  la déflation et une fois que nous avons eu
la déflation, nous avons pu assouplir la politique monétaire, la
politique budgétaire et le crédit pour aider l'
économie réelle parce que nous avons eu le problème
d'une faible inflation, pas assez
aujourd'hui, nous avons le pire des années 1970
parce que nous avons les chocs négatifs de l'offre,
la stagflation mais nous avons  quatre
fois plus de dette que dans les années 70 et nous
entrons dans une récession, non pas en réduisant
les taux directeurs mais en les augmentant parce que nous
avons maintenant de l'inflation,
donc vous avez un problème d'inflation, vous avez un problème de
stagflation et vous
avez un problème d'endettement, une
dette excessive aussi
maintenant si
vous  ne sont pas disposés
à résoudre ce problème en augmentant
les impôts ou en réduisant les dépenses
la solution est l'inflation l'impôt
vous monétisez le déficit vous provoquez
l'inflation et l'inflation quand elle n'est pas
prévue réduit la valeur réelle de la
dette nominale de longue durée
à des taux d'intérêt fixes la valeur réelle
de cette dette est réduite par l'inflation, c'est
effectivement comme une taxe sur le capital, une
taxe sur les épargnants et les créanciers et le
transfert d'argent et de revenus aux débiteurs
et aux emprunteurs
par la taxe sur l'inflation qui sera la
solution à ce problème,
en fait, nous aurons un taux plus élevé.
l'inflation
parce que nous sommes dans ce piège, il y a
tellement de dette dans le système que si vous
augmentez suffisamment les taux d'intérêt pour lutter contre l'
inflation,
non seulement vous provoquez une récession, vous
provoquez également une crise de la dette et, face au
risque d'un
krach économique et financier, les banques centrales
parlent dur, ils vont se
dégonfler, ils vont cligner des yeux, ils vont
devenir conciliants parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas se permettre
un grave krach économique et financier,
donc nous nous retrouvons avec des niveaux d'inflation plus élevés
de manière plus permanente, je
pense que c'est le résultat  la
façon dont vous le gérez est la partie qui présente le
moins de résistance d'un point
de vue politique
pour procéder avec l'économie de la foi.
[La musique]
est
[la musique]
étrangère
et bien, il a reçu le prix parce qu'il
était un spécialiste de la Grande Dépression
et pendant la  Grande Dépression le
krach boursier de 29 est devenu une
dépression parce que nous avons laissé de nombreux
agriculteurs, de nombreuses entreprises, de nombreuses banques, des
millions d'entre eux s'effondrer,
beaucoup d'entre eux étaient illiquides, ils n'avaient pas
assez de liquidités, ils n'étaient pas
nécessairement en faillite, mais en ne
leur fournissant pas de suivi de soutien
crédit un problème de liquidité est devenu un
problème d'insolvabilité ils ont fait faillite
et quelque chose qu'ils ont déclenché le
choc financier est devenu une Grande Dépression c'était un
effondrement de la demande une déflation et ainsi de suite
lorsque la crise financière mondiale
s'est produite,
la leçon était que nous devrions faire suffisamment d'efforts
monétaires et fiscaux  et un assouplissement du crédit pour
éviter que cette Grande Récession ne se transforme en
Grande Dépression 2.0
et il est logique de mettre en place un filet de sécurité
pour certaines parties du secteur privé et public,
mais
l'augmentation de ce montant s'est produite, passant de
100 % du PIB dans les années 70 à 420.
aujourd'hui, c'est que chaque fois qu'il y a une
bulle,
nous ne l'arrêtons pas
et les gens continuent à suremprunter
et la bulle conduit à plus de dettes et
d'endettement, puis lorsque le krach se produit,
nous disons oh mon Dieu, il y a un
risque systémique, il doit y avoir un
crise financière, une dépression, puis nous
assouplissons les
coûts, ce qui rend les coûts d'emprunt
bon marché et conduit à un autre cycle d'
emprunt encore plus important,
donc nous n'arrêtons pas la bulle dans les bons
moments et nous essayons ensuite de protéger les gens
de leur effondrement.  d'une
bulle au moment du coucher et ces
réponses asymétriques impliquent plus de bulles plus
d'endettement plus de prise de risque dans les
bons moments, puis renflouer
tout le monde dans les mauvais moments, ce qui provoque un
risque moral, ce que les gens appellent monalaza, que
si vous êtes protégé et assuré, vous
allez  prendre plus de risques que vous ne le devriez, ce qui
conduit à un biais d'accumulation
excessive de vétérans
et Ben Bernanke
a écrit des articles expliquant pourquoi nous ne devrions pas essayer de
faire une bulle dans Good Times, cela dit trop
dangereux
et il a dit que lorsque la Bible devient
excessive et va  l'éclatement, alors nous
devons protéger le système d'un
effondrement total comme la Grande Dépression, mais
ne rien faire dans les bons moments,
puis gérer la bulle exposée,
créer ces biais vers plus de bulles,
plus de dette, plus d'effet de levier, c'est donc son
erreur intellectuelle,
il a bien appris quelques leçons  de la
Grande Dépression, mais je n'ai pas tiré les
leçons de ce que signifie avoir
trop d'endettement et perdre la politique monétaire
Christina
candidats
étrangers
[Musique] [
Musique]
tout d'abord, j'ai rencontré à plusieurs reprises,
elle est une décideuse politique très avisée, elle
a beaucoup d'expérience
elle a été ministre des Finances en France elle a
dirigé le fonds monétaire international
maintenant la Banque centrale européenne elle n'est pas
économiste de formation elle est avocate
mais elle a appris beaucoup d'économie et
le lien entre l'économie et la
politique et la politique
donc elle  est un
décideur politique de grande qualité, comme tous les décideurs politiques,
euh, elle est soumise à des contraintes, vous savez que
les décideurs politiques ne sont pas stupides, ils ne sont pas
méchants, ils ne sont pas stupides, ils ne veulent pas
causer de dégâts,
le problème auquel la BCE est confrontée aujourd'hui
est l'
inflation.  a beaucoup augmenté dans la zone euro
en partie à cause de ces chocs d'offre négatifs,
mais en partie aussi parce que les
mesures de relance monétaire, budgétaire et de crédit
après le codevid ont été trop fortes pendant
trop longtemps, c'était l'erreur politique,
mais
en ce moment,
vous vous trouvez face à un dilemme
si vous  augmenter les intérêts c'est suffisant pour
lutter contre l'inflation vous risquez de provoquer une
récession et une récession sévère
et si vous n'augmentez pas les intérêts c'est
suffisant pour lutter contre l'inflation
vous risquez d'avoir un désancrage de
l'inflation et des anticipations d'inflation et
un prix
dans lequel spirale qui mène à  une
inflation élevée comme dans les années 70, alors bon sang si vous
les faites si vous ne le faites pas, mais maintenant il y a une
couche supplémentaire de stress
à mesure que vous augmentez les taux d'intérêt comme je l'ai dit
de nombreux gouvernements de la zone euro, certaines banques,
certains gouvernements, certaines entreprises, certains
ménages, certains travaux ont beaucoup  de la dette
et comme vous êtes aussi intéressé, il y a un
risque que certains d'entre eux fassent faillite,
deviennent insolvables et que le
krach financier endommage l'économie réelle et qu'une
économie réelle plus faible aggrave encore plus le
problème de la dette, donc il y a aussi un risque d'
instabilité financière
Maintenant, la BCE a créé ce nouvel
instrument appelé instrument de protection de la transmission TPI
qui dit que si le spread
d'un membre de la zone euro devient
trop élevé, ce qui entraîne le risque d'un
problème de dette pour le gouvernement
tant que l'augmentation du spread est
due  le simple fait de paniquer face
à la dynamique du marché
n'est pas justifié par les
fondamentaux économiques, alors la BCE pourrait
acheter les obligations de ce pays et
empêcher une crise désordonnée de
se produire.
Cependant, dans la pratique, la raison pour laquelle les
spreads d'un pays peuvent augmenter n'est pas
simplement  parce que les gens sont irrationnels sur
les marchés, mais peut-être parce qu'il y a une
politique budgétaire laxiste, il y a un manque de
réformes économiques. Regardez ce qui s'est passé
au Royaume-Uni lorsque la
relance budgétaire a ensuite été punie par
les marchés avec une augmentation de leur spread et une
baisse de leur monnaie.  valeur
afin que la DCB puisse aider les pays à faire ce qu'il
faut, mais ils n'ont pas de chance à
cause d'investisseurs irrationnels, mais si
la raison pour laquelle l'écart augmente est
due à leurs propres erreurs politiques,
alors le CV ne pourra pas
les aider et alors  vous risquez que
cette crise soit désordonnée, donc c'est un autre
niveau de complication dans la
prise de décision de la Banque centrale européenne, ce
n'est pas facile,
c'est
[Musique]
certains pourcentages,
bien chaque fois qu'il y a une dette excessive,
euh il y a potentiellement de nombreuses solutions,
chacun d'entre eux a  des avantages à un certain
prix,
bien sûr, la meilleure solution à ce
problème est une croissance économique élevée, car
c'est un ratio dans le niveau de la
dette et un certain revenu si votre revenu
augmente votre dette devient plus viable
le ratio dette/revenu diminue
bien sûr, c'est un vœu pieux
parce que lorsque la dette est élevée, la croissance
diminue
et lorsque la croissance est plus faible, le taux d'endettement
devient plus élevé, vous vous retrouvez donc dans le
cercle vicieux,
disent certaines personnes, si votre dette est trop élevée,
économisez, dépensez moins
et serrez-vous la ceinture
au niveau individuel, ce qui fonctionne si je
J'ai trop de dettes et je dépense moins,
j'épargne plus, je peux réduire mes dettes, mais si
tout le monde dans l'économie
dépense moins, épargne plus, cela aggrave la
récession et, à mesure qu'une récession est
pire, les revenus chutent et votre ratio dette/
revenu devient plus élevé, c'est ce que
Keynes  appelé le paradoxe de l'épargne, le
paradoxe de l'épargne collective de ce qui est individuellement
rationnel peut en fait être
la mauvaise réponse
maintenant si vous empruntez
dans une devise étrangère
et que vous avez trop de dettes, vous n'avez pas d'autre
choix que de faire défaut et ensuite de
restructurer votre dette négocier une
réduction  de votre dette, c'est ce que
font les marchés émergents,
la différence est cependant que dans
les économies avancées comme la nôtre et l'Europe
qui empruntent dans leur propre monnaie,
vous pouvez réduire la valeur réelle de votre
dette nominale en ayant une
inflation surprise car l'inflation implique que
votre coût d'emprunt en réel  les conditions sont
réduites et la valeur réelle de votre dette
est inférieure,
donc une inflation inattendue est une forme de
défaut que vous continuez à taxer les épargnants et les
créanciers et que vous transférez bien au
débiteur et aux emprunteurs, mais cela ne se fait pas
par défaut formel, cela se fait par le biais de la
taxe sur l'inflation,
une autre  la solution peut être la
répression financière vous forcez les banques à détenir
votre dette du gouvernement et si la
demande de données est élevée le
taux d'intérêt est plus bas mais la taxe sur le
système financier une autre solution est vous
taxez les riches vous avez une
fiscalité sur la fortune vous expropriez  la richesse et
ensuite vous l'utilisez pour rembourser votre dette,
mais c'est encore une fois une forme de taxation des
créanciers et des épargnants et de
transfert d'argent aux emprunteurs,
ils sont donc tous des variantes de la même
monétisation par défaut, inflation, taxation du capital,
ex-propodisation,
répression financière
pure et simple.  par défaut et structuration, il
existe des variantes de la même idée lorsqu'il y
a trop de dettes, vous devez donc choisir
votre poison, déterminer lequel d'entre eux
est le moins dommageable et cela dépend de nombreuses
variables différentes.  un
petit
poison chaque jour
est qui vous protège contre le poison
vous rend plus immunisé ou est une petite
dette lente, je pense que c'est probablement plus ce
dernier que le premier, c'est
comme faire bouillir un Frogger lentement,
vous le faites bouillir lentement mais finalement vous
tuez la grenouille  avec une mort au ralenti
parce que l'
Afrique du Sud
va
bien, il n'y avait pas que Janet Yellen, la
Fed, la Banque centrale, presque tous les
décideurs politiques des économies avancées
n'ont pas vu cette inflation arriver
d'un côté, ils ont fait une erreur
de l'autre côté, mais aussi de nombreuses économies
et Wall  Street a fait la même erreur
parce que pendant 20 ans, le problème dans les
économies avancées n'était pas une inflation élevée, mais
avec un objectif de 2 pour cent
et l'inflation était inférieure à 2 pour cent,
parfois proche de zéro
après la crise financière mondiale, la
déflation
au début de la crise de la convoitise
également.  une déflation parce que la baisse de la
demande était supérieure à la baisse de l'
offre
et que pendant la crise financière mondiale,
nous n'avions pas suffisamment de mesures de relance monétaire et
budgétaire et que la reprise était
anémique, la croissance a repris mais très lentement,
le taux de chômage est resté élevé et n'a
diminué que lentement,
donc  Lorsque le choc de couverture médiatique s'est produit,
tout le monde, à droite comme à
gauche, a dit que nous avions fait une erreur pendant la
crise financière mondiale, que nous n'avions pas
suffisamment suivi les mesures de relance budgétaire et de crédit
cette fois-ci puisque le
choc semble plus important, faisons une relance massive,
le problème était  celui-là, la relance
était d'une ampleur sans ordre trois quatre
fois supérieure en tant que PIB sûr à ce qu'ils
avaient fait 10 ans auparavant,
deuxièmement, la crise financière mondiale était
une crise civile qui a duré deux ou trois
ans alors que le choc tant convoité en termes
de récession datait de février  de 2020
jusqu'en mai, juin a été une récession très courte et
superficielle qui a duré à peine
deux trimestres au maximum et avec la réouverture de
l'économie alors que nous avons aplati la courbe
et avec les mesures de relance fiscales, monétaires et de
crédit massives, l'économie a commencé à se
redresser rapidement, de sorte que la relance en est devenue une
également.  beaucoup trop long et excessif d'un
côté,
deuxièmement, à court terme, les hommes échouent
plus que l'offre, mais ensuite la demande
a récupéré même la relance, mais les gens
n'ont pas réalisé parce qu'ils n'avaient pas vu de
chocs d'offre négatifs depuis les années 70,
que le Covid était également un choc d'offre négatif
réduisant  la production de biens
et de services
réduisant l'offre de main-d'œuvre créant
des goulots d'étranglement dans les chaînes d'approvisionnement mondiales,
ce fut le premier choc, puis en
2022 l'année dernière avec une autre langue Le
choc de l'offre la surprise des décideurs politiques
l'invasion russe de l'Ukraine qui a
augmenté tous les prix du gaz naturel les
engrais alimentaires  et les métaux industriels et
le commerce ont été un autre troisième choc d'offre négatif
qui était la politique de convoitise zéro de la
Chine, la production de Chatham en Chine
et a créé des goulots d'étranglement supplémentaires de l'offre mondiale, de sorte que l'
inflation a été
maîtrisée en raison d'une combinaison de mauvaises
politiques,
de surveillance lâche de l'utilisation du budget et du crédit,
mais aussi  Pas de chance, au moins trois
chocs négatifs sur l'offre globale, donc les
décideurs politiques ont fait des erreurs, mais vous
devez également essayer de comprendre pourquoi ils ont commis
ces erreurs.
coupons
étrangers
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
euh, les marchés financiers, j'ai acheté
des fonctions positives
de  prendre des économies et les affecter aux
bons projets d'investissement
financer des choses qui sont utiles
comme des hypothèques pour que vous puissiez acheter une maison
ou divers types de prêts personnels pour
atténuer les chocs sur vos revenus ou accorder des
prêts commerciaux qui permettent aux entreprises de se
développer
mais comme tout le reste  si cet
emprunt devient excessif
si les critères de crédit s'assouplissent
si vous êtes autorisé à assortir la dette,
trop d'endettement et trop de prise de risque,
alors vous alimentez une bulle parce que
les gens empruntent de l'argent pour acheter des actifs, la
valeur de l'actif augmente alors qu'ils  Vous pouvez
utiliser ces actifs comme garantie pour
emprunter davantage et vous entrez dans une
bulle de crédit et d'actifs
dans laquelle les gens deviennent alors arrogants et prennent le
risque de fraude
et tout cela conduit finalement à un
boom et à une bulle, puis finalement à un
effondrement.  crash et vous avez raison, les
êtres humains seront toujours
avides, certains d'entre eux, en particulier sur les
marchés financiers, ce n'est pas seulement le
marché financier aujourd'hui, euh ces dernières
années, une jeune génération de compétences désespérées de la jeune génération
Z, moins de revenus sans emploi,
moins ils font du day trading,
ils  ils achètent des actions Mimi, ils achètent des crypto-monnaies
en croyant qu'ils peuvent devenir riches du jour au lendemain,
personne n'est devenu riche du jour au lendemain, une
personne peut être sur un million, tout le
monde perd son argent,
donc ce n'est pas seulement un petit groupe de
spéculateurs de Wall Street et de gens cupides
qui posent problème maintenant.  Comme nous le voyons,
tout le monde joue
avec l'argent et a ce type d'
illusion.
Bien sûr, le travail de la politique monétaire,
le travail des superviseurs et des régulateurs du
système financier serait d'arrêter
la bulle,
car avant qu'elle ne devienne excessive,
vous pouvez le faire en augmentant  taux d'intérêt,
vous pouvez le faire par des contrôles de crédit, vous
pouvez le faire en limitant l'effet de levier et
toute une série de politiques prudentielles
visant à éviter les bulles de crédit excessives
qui provoquent des bulles d'actifs.
Le problème est que dans les bons moments, la
mise en œuvre de ces politiques est difficile pour
le politicien et les emprunteurs.
Plaignez-vous et dites que vous ne me laissez pas
investir pour emprunter et je le fais pour de
bonnes raisons
et les régulateurs sont souvent capturés par
Wall Street et par l'industrie, parfois
les politiciens sont corrompus
et quoi qu'il y ait une bulle, nous trouvons
une histoire
expliquant pourquoi  il y a une nouvelle révolution technologique majeure,
Internet, les chemins de fer, la cryptographie,
quoi que ce soit qui justifie d'investir et
de tirer parti de la bulle et bien sûr,
ce sont des fantasmes et ils finissent en
larmes, mais entre-temps, la bulle
devient incontrôlable jusqu'à ce qu'elle explose,
puis la suivante.  on arrive donc ce sont
des cycles en principe qui contrôlent que nous
pourrions contrôler avec une monnaie serrée
Taux d'intérêt élevés Contrôles des
capitaux contrôles du crédit
Réglementation prudentielle Supervision des
banques Banques fantômes Système financier
réduisant les dérivés toxiques
réduisant la financiarisation toxique et ainsi de
suite mais nous ne le faisons pas
donc nous passons par ces cycles encore et
encore
étrangers
[Musique]
ouais, j'ai été personnellement euh
sceptique à l'égard des crypto-monnaies et un critique à
leur égard déjà depuis
2016-17 et j'ai gardé mon point de vue
que là où la plupart d'entre elles sont  escroquer
un jeu de Ponzi
fraude criminelle une bulle qui va
finir par éclater
et regardez l'année dernière seulement
au cours des 12 derniers mois,
même Bitcoin a perdu 80 pour cent de sa
valeur passant de 69 000 à 16. Ethereum
a perdu plus de 80 pour cent
l'autre top 10  d'entre eux ont perdu entre 80
et 90 pour cent et bien sûr,
des dizaines de milliers
de ces offres initiales de pièces d'icos
étaient une arnaque au début avec des gens
volant de l'argent pour acheter des voitures
Lamborghini Villas, des bateaux, des avions dans les
Caraïbes, Miami, littéralement de la racaille et un
comportement criminel, 99 d'entre eux sont  de cette façon, les
appeler des crypto-monnaies
est un terme abusif, ils ne sont pas de l'argent, ils ne sont
pas une monnaie,
ils ne sont pas une unité de compte car
rien n'est tarifé en Bitcoin,
ils ne sont pas un moyen de paiement évolutif
car avec Bitcoin, vous pouvez  effectuez sept
transactions par seconde
avec le réseau VISA en 50 000
transactions par seconde,
ils ne constituent pas une réserve de valeur stable
car la valeur du Bitcoin peut augmenter
ou diminuer de 10 à 20 du jour au lendemain, c'est pourquoi même
les conférences crypto n'acceptent pas le
paiement de leur  frais en Bitcoin car
toute la marge bénéficiaire de la
conférence peut être effacée du jour au lendemain
et finalement
ils ne sont pas un seul numérateur,
un seul numérateur signifie que j'ai besoin d'un
compte unitaire pour pouvoir comparer le prix
du pain par opposition au prix de la
viande.  prix relatif inférieur à deux,
vous avez donc besoin d'un seul chiffre dans un monde de
tokenisation où il y a des milliers
de jetons
si j'ai besoin d'un jeton Pepsi pour acheter du Pepsi
Cola et que c'est un Coca qui parle pour acheter du
Coca-Cola, je ne peux même plus dire le
prix relatif entre  Coca-Cola et
Pepsi entre le pain et la viande, c'est comme
revenir littéralement au troc,
même même aux Pierrafeu, vous connaissez l'
histoire de dessin animé sur les gens de l'âge de pierre, ils
sont le système monétaire plus avancé
que la crypto parce qu'ils sont le
seul numérateur qui utilise  décortiquez la
coquille où se trouve l'unité de compte afin que vous
puissiez dire à la presse de la mariée par rapport à la
presse de la viande en crypto que vous êtes de retour au
troc, donc les appeler des devises, de l'argent
qu'ils ne sont pas n'a aucun sens,
ils ne sont même pas des actifs
généralement un atout car certaines
actions à revenu vous donnent des dividendes les
obligations vous donnent des paiements de coupons les
obligations vous donnent des intérêts
un prêt commercial un prêt bancaire vous donne des
intérêts l'
immobilier vous donne un loyer
ou vous avez le service de location de
votre maison Les
matières premières le pétrole l'énergie la nourriture donnent  vous les
services de
ces gars-là n'ont aucun revenu maintenant l'
or n'a pas de revenus mais il avait les
bijoux utilitaires
et utilise l'industrie comme l'or l'argent
est utilisé pour la production de divers types
de biens et services
prenez Bitcoin
n'a pas  le revenu
n'a aucune utilisation l'industrie
n'a aucune utilité personne ne
porte des bijoux Bitcoin en fait, certaines
personnes ringardes les portent mais ils sont
vraiment laids, il n'y aura pas beaucoup de
bijoux qui deviendront populaires
et donc vous ne pouvez même pas valoriser
Bitcoin parce que vous avez besoin d'un  soit un flux
de revenus, soit un flux d'utilisation ou une
utilité extrême que vous pouvez faire pour en tirer la
valeur actualisée afin que vous puissiez évaluer
la valeur d'un actif, il est donc
impossible de fixer le prix de ces choses, c'est
pourquoi certaines personnes disent que Bitcoin va
être un  millions et d'autres personnes disent que ça
va être zéro, à mon avis, la
valeur fondamentale du Bitcoin est zéro
zéro en fait, c'est négatif, ce n'est pas
zéro
parce que
Bitcoin a une énorme
externalité environnementale négative, utilise tellement d'
énergie pour le produire
que les Pays-Bas ou l'Argentine
que si  il y avait la bonne taxe carbone
sur le Bitcoin la valeur du Bitcoin ne serait pas
nulle sera négative étant donné la
taxe carbone pour faire face à l'externalité
du Bitcoin donc ce ne sont pas des monnaies
ce ne sont pas des actifs
ce sont des arnaques une bande d'escrocs des
fraudeurs  les
fraudeurs fiscaux, les terroristes et d'autres personnes
se livrant à des activités illégales comme le trafic d'êtres humains
les utilisent, c'est la
seule utilisation pour des activités illégales, donc
c'est une arnaque totale, une criminalité totale
et SBF SBF, le chef de FTX ne fait pas
exception,
c'est la règle qu'ils sont  tous des racailles, ce sont tous
des jeux de Ponzi et ils sont tous criminels dans
Crooks, ils devraient tous finir en prison,
ils ne sont pas tous des criminels,
presque tous
euh,
je pense que les deux choses sont en fait
corrélées
parce que
ce qui s'est passé aux États-Unis en Anglo-  Le
pays saxon était que pendant longtemps, les
revenus des gens n'augmentaient pas suffisamment
par rapport à leur propre demande, attentes
en matière de dépenses et de consommation,
car ils disaient que les Américains ne pouvaient pas suivre
le rythme des Jones, chaque famille se
comparait aux voisins
et disait qu'ils avaient l'air plus riches.  ils ont l'
auto, la plus grosse voiture à la maison, quelle que soit
la solution qui a été proposée
dans le pays anglo-saxon, c'est ce qu'ils
appellent la démocratisation de la finance.
J'aimerais que vous ayez beaucoup de cartes de crédit.
J'aimerais que vous empruntiez pour acheter votre  voiture
Je vous laisse emprunter pour votre
prêt étudiant J'aime emprunter autant que vous le
souhaitez pour acheter une maison et mettre très peu de
valeur nette
et à mesure que la valeur de votre maison
augmente parce que tout s'emprunte,
vous pouvez emprunter encore plus.  Ce qu'on
appelle le retrait de la valeur nette de la maison, la valeur de la
pièce est plus élevée, laissez-moi contracter un prêt
sur la valeur la plus élevée afin que je puisse dépenser
plus que mon revenu parce que votre revenu
n'était pas suffisant pour financer toutes vos
dépenses, vous utilisez donc efficacement votre
maison comme un distributeur automatique de billets.  et emprunter
sur elle et vous permettre un style de vie que vous
ne pouviez pas vous permettre, donc le problème de l'hypothèque
et le problème de la consommation sont les
deux faces du même problème :
vous utilisez votre maison comme un distributeur automatique de billets,
vous empruntez sur elle pour financer
une consommation supérieure à vos revenus.  donc la
bulle hypothécaire était aussi une
bulle de consommation et lorsque la bulle hypothécaire s'est
accentuée, la bulle de consommation a
éclaté
et le problème fondamental est qu'il y a des
revenus et des inégalités de richesse. Les
revenus réels n'augmentent pas suffisamment le coût de l'
éducation, des soins de santé, des retraites ou de
l'achat d'un  la maison des services est en hausse et
les gens sont désespérés et quand ils sont
désespérés, ils financent leur
consommation excessive, comparent leurs revenus en
empruntant et vous avez une bulle de dette et
vous gagnez de l'argent à bas prix, ils empruntent encore
plus jusqu'à ce que la bulle économique éclate
[Musique] eh
bien, je'  m en principe en faveur du libre-
échange de la mondialisation de la migration du
capital du travail ou davantage d'échanges de biens
dans les services
euh dans les technologies de l'information de données
le pays qui s'est intégré au niveau mondial
a bien fait
supposons que vous preniez les 27 ou 28
pays de l'Union européenne si  il n'y avait
pas eu d'Union européenne, il y
aurait de petites économies, de petits marchés et
ils ne pourraient pas croître aussi vite que les
marchés étrangers en Europe
ou dans le monde,
donc la plupart des pays d'Europe et de la
zone euro ont en fait bénéficié
de la mondialisation.
Regardez la Chine.  ou en Inde, ils étaient si pauvres
et ils ont commencé à le devenir moins lorsqu'ils se sont
ouverts à l'économie mondiale et ont
rejoint les marchés mondiaux. L'
offre mondiale de main-d'œuvre.
Regardez l'exemple de la Corée du Nord et de la Corée du Sud,
au moment de la guerre de Corée, le Nord était
beaucoup plus riche que  le Sud que les
ressources naturelles que la
Corée manufacturière leur offre,
mais pourriez-vous investir dans les
compétences en matière d'éducation du capital humain et est maintenant une
économie avancée alors que les gens
meurent encore de faim en Corée du Nord, le pays exclu
bien sûr, mais la
migration de la mondialisation commerciale conduit à des gagnants
et des perdants
si vous êtes un ouvrier à faible valeur ajoutée
dans des économies avancées dans un
secteur de l'économie à forte intensité de main-d'œuvre
manufacturière, alors vos emplois, vos
revenus peuvent être menacés par des produits bon marché
en provenance de Chine ou d'autres
marchés émergents, mais c'est un phénomène naturel.
système économique
et bien sûr, nous aurions dû aider
ceux qui ont perdu leur emploi en leur offrant une
formation de recyclage afin qu'ils puissent accéder
à d'autres emplois, mais nous avons échoué. Nous avons réussi à ce que le
commerce crée suffisamment de
gains économiques pour que vous puissiez taxer ceux qui sont
gagnants, transférer des revenus ou des compétences à
ceux-là.  qui sont laissés pour compte et vous pouvez
toujours améliorer la situation de tout le monde,
mais nous n'avons pas fait en sorte que
les gagnants obtiennent une plus grande part des
bénéfices alors que ceux qui étaient des perdants ou laissés pour
compte n'ont jamais été aidés et ce fut
le début de la réaction des
cols bleus.  les travailleurs et d'autres contre le commerce
, la mondialisation et la migration, etc.,
en principe, la mondialisation est une
bonne idée, mais vous devez faire face aux
effets distributifs du commerce,
sinon vous risquez d'aggraver la situation d'une bonne partie de
votre pays plutôt que d'être une
affaire d'
étrangers.
]
selon la section de classe
est
[Musique]
Amérique
et oui, il y a une possibilité qu'il y
ait des recours collectifs
contre les sociétés énergétiques de la même manière qu'il
y avait des poursuites similaires
contre les compagnies de tabac,
ce qui constitue une menace potentielle pour certains  de
leurs bénéfices
et de leurs gains
euh mais je dirais que nous ne savons pas
encore si
ces pertes seront couronnées de succès en termes de
frais qu'ils devront payer
ou d'amendes
et je dirais qu'à court terme ce que
The Old Company  Ce qui nous inquiète le plus,
c'est que depuis que les prix de l'énergie sont élevés,
les bénéfices de ces anciennes sociétés ont
augmenté très fortement et maintenant, dans de nombreux
pays, il existe une opinion selon laquelle nous
devrions les taxer sur ces bénéfices extraordinaires
parce qu'ils sont excessifs et nous choisissons d'
imposer ces bénéfices.  pour
transférer des revenus aux ménages ou
aux entreprises qui souffrent des prix élevés de l'énergie, il
est maintenant logique d'essayer de taxer
ces super profits anormaux,
c'est l'argument en faveur, mais le
contre-argument est que dans un monde
où les prix de l'énergie sont élevés parce que
il n'y a pas assez d'approvisionnement en énergie si
vous les taxez et déjà toutes les entreprises
investissent dans une nouvelle production de combustibles
fossiles, elles peuvent en produire encore moins
et alors la contrainte d'approvisionnement devient
plus élevée et le coût de l'énergie pourrait
également devenir plus élevé, donc trouver le bon
la réponse n'est pas si simple, il est facile de
blâmer les grandes sociétés pétrolières, vous êtes riche, vous gagnez tout
cet argent, laissez-moi vous taxer, alors vous
devez réfléchir aux conséquences,
par exemple,
je suis tout à fait favorable à la lutte contre le
changement climatique mondial.
et parce que nous nous inquiétons des émissions
provenant des combustibles fossiles, nous dénigrons les
grandes sociétés pétrolières
et nous disons à Cheryl que des
parties prenantes disent à vos entreprises de
sous-investir dans les combustibles fossiles et de se lancer
dans les énergies renouvelables et nous disons aux
banques d'essayer de ne pas financer  les grandes vieilles entreprises si
elles n'investissent pas dans les énergies renouvelables
maintenant, toute cette pression sur les
actionnaires, les gouvernements, la société sociale et
les banques implique que depuis cinq à dix
ans, les grandes vieilles entreprises, en particulier les
entreprises privées, ont sous-investi dans de
nouvelles capacités de nouveaux domaines de
combustibles fossiles, de sorte que le  l'approvisionnement en combustibles fossiles diminue
mais l'approvisionnement en énergies renouvelables
n'augmente pas assez vite pour compenser
la baisse de la capacité d'approvisionnement en
combustibles fossiles, nous avons donc maintenant un
manque structurel d'approvisionnement en énergie,
donc même le bœuf avant
l'invasion russe de l'Ukraine  Le Brent,
qui est un indice de tous les prix, était déjà proche
d'une centaine de dollars le baril,
donc ce n'est pas seulement la
grue d'invasion russe qui a provoqué la
flambée de tous les prix, mais aussi
le sous-investissement dans la capacité des combustibles fossiles
en raison du dénigrement et du va-et-vient.
après le Big Oil, voilà quelques-uns des
effets secondaires de politiques bien intentionnées
qui ont
des conséquences inattendues
[Musique] l'
essence,
c'est une initiative polynomiale super normale
[Musique]
vous savez, copier Glasgow
et le flic de Sharma Sheikh
ont été un échec et non  seulement parce que
les dirigeants d'une vieille entreprise peuvent avoir
trop d'influence parce que la plupart des
entreprises ne sont pas seulement toutes les entreprises qui
élaborent ces plans net zéro, mais leurs
plans net zéro sont rédigés par leurs
services de communication et de relations publiques, ils
ne sont pas rédigés par les gestionnaires ou les
scientifiques  donc tout le monde doit prétendre
que dans 20 ans nous atteindrons
zéro, ils écrivent un livre blanc, il n'y a pas de
substance mais de cette façon, ils sauvent la
face et bien sûr ils font un peu de
maquillage ici et là pour économiser de l'énergie
et réduire leur empreinte carbone
mais comme je l'ai dit, tout n'est que du green washing, c'est du
green wish,
donc même si tous les engagements des
deux derniers flics devaient être pris et c'est
un gros problème car ni les États-Unis, ni l'Europe,
ni les marchés émergents ne feront ce qu'ils ont
dit, mais même avec  leurs engagements actuels
on va aller vers une hausse des températures
y'a pas 1,5
c'est pas deux deux grigoreux c'est le
niveau actuel on va vers une trajectoire de 2,4
même si on fait tout ce qu'on a promis et
comme on ne va pas faire tout ce
qu'on promet le  le nombre d'ici la fin de ce
siècle pourrait être de plus trois
1,5 est mauvais
deux est moche
trois est un désastre vers lequel
nous sommes sur la voie plus trois
soyons réalistes à ce sujet
et tout le monde blanchit les
positions,
vous connaissez le forum de Dallas et j'y suis allé
de nombreuses années, ce n'est pas chaque année l'un des
nombreux forums et il y en a des tonnes d'
autres où les dirigeants mondiaux se
réunissent et discutent des
problèmes économiques mondiaux, maintenant ils résolvent les
problèmes, non, mais d'autres forums n'importe quelle
conférence dans le monde dont vous parlez, vous
débattez de choses que vous essayez  pour trouver
des solutions, mais ce ne sont pas des formes de
prise de décisions, les décisions sont prises
au niveau national ou au
niveau international dans d'autres types de quatre comme le FMI, la
Banque mondiale, l'ONU et ainsi de suite la
nuit, à mon avis, les
gens se réunissent
et se parlent  plutôt que de
se faire la guerre, c'est une bonne idée,
c'est une bonne idée d'
avoir des dirigeants mondiaux
économiques, politiques, religieux, culturels, etc., c'est
une bonne idée et bien sûr,
au cours des dernières décennies, leur
femme a été sensible au fait que
nos problèmes sociaux  il y a donc des
entrepreneurs sociaux et des dirigeants de
divers types d'
organisations environnementales et d'autres qui se soucient des
droits du travail, etc., ils essaient donc d'être
plus représentatifs d'un plus large
éventail de points de vue sur toutes ces questions,
c'est donc un bon forum.  beaucoup d'
autres sont aussi bons où les gens se
réunissent et discutent, c'est plus un
atelier de discussion plutôt qu'un atelier d'action
euh c'est utile mais je ne crois pas qu'un
individu seul, un forum ou une
organisation
puisse résoudre les problèmes mondiaux,
euh vous savez, sur le
pandémie mondiale l'Organisation mondiale de la santé
Les Who
n'ont pas réussi
sur les questions commerciales nous allons vers des
protectionnistes la démondialisation et l'
OMC l'Organisation mondiale du commerce a des
pouvoirs limités
l'ONU a des pouvoirs limités pour faire respecter la
sécurité mondiale le FMI et la
Banque mondiale font le bien  mais ils ont des
pouvoirs limités, donc nous n'avons pas encore d'institutions
de gouvernance mondiale qui soient
suffisamment puissantes pour appliquer la prise de décision mondiale.  ils
ont une légitimité démocratique, ils nous
enlèvent la souveraineté nationale, mais vous
savez que nous vivons dans un monde où les
problèmes sont une pandémie mondiale de
changement climatique.
plus
La gouvernance mondiale n'en est pas moins
et malheureusement maintenant il y a davantage de
réactions nationalistes. Je veux
protéger mon pays, mes travailleurs, mes entreprises
et si vous faites cela, vous allez vers
le protectionnisme, mais vous connaissez
mes taxes sur vos exportations qui sont mes
importations, réduisez vos exportations.  mais si vous
ripostez contre moi, vos tarifs réduisent
mes experts et si vous démarrez une guerre
de représailles en
augmentant les taxes à l'importation des deux côtés,
tout le monde est dans une situation pire et nous avons un
monde pire plutôt qu'un monde meilleur,
alors bien sûr, la mondialisation et le commerce ont
des conséquences.  le coût auquel nous devons faire face,
la croissance doit être durable doit être
inclusive, c'est lutter contre les inégalités, mais le
protectionnisme commercial n'est pas la bonne
solution,
voyez-vous, Luca a
raison, certains des coûts du
changement climatique sont la perte de près de la moitié des
animaux
et
plantes sur la planète
parce que nous avons cette
vision anthropomorphique où tout est envoyé autour de l'
humain et de la sapience et nous ne nous soucions pas
autant du bien-être des animaux et
des plantes nous ne votons pas nous ne disons jamais
bien sûr endommager la planète
détruire  les plantes et les animaux
ont un certain nombre d'effets secondaires qui sont
causés même aux êtres humains
et la destruction de la planète crée des dégâts
ouragans élévation du niveau de la mer sécheresses
inondations incendies de forêt qui ont un
coût économique énorme, même pour les humains et encore
moins pour les animaux, mais comme je le dis,  Nous l'avons
souligné avant de faire quelque chose contre le
changement climatique mondial, nous sommes soumis à un large
éventail de contraintes politiques nationales et
internationales qui
nous empêchent de bien faire
ce qu'il faut.  le
progrès de la paix et
la prospérité disent après 1945
et nous pensons que l'avenir
sera comme le passé proche
et nous le projetons de cette façon,
mais je pense que c'est une erreur
pour un certain nombre de raisons,
tout d'abord même dans ces 75 années,
la période entre 1945
et jusqu'au début des années 80 c'était très
différent des 20 dernières années
et je vais vous donner la
description suivante je suis assez vieux tu es
plus jeune que moi j'ai 64 ans. Je suis né dans
les années 50
et j'ai grandi à 60 70  début des années 80 entre le
Moyen-Orient et l'Europe jusqu'à mon arrivée aux
États-Unis maintenant, quand j'ai grandi,
je ne me suis jamais inquiété de la guerre entre les grandes
puissances et de l'hiver nucléaire, des railleries de
Nixon en Chine, très peu. Je ne m'inquiète
jamais du changement climatique.
à propos des pandémies, je n'en ai même jamais entendu
parler, la dernière était la grippe espagnole de 1918,
je ne me suis jamais inquiété de la destruction de la plupart des
emplois par l'IA, il n'y avait pas d'IA, oui, il y avait de l'IA,
théorie de l'hiver,
je ne me suis jamais inquiété de la démondialisation
et du protectionnisme avec l'intégration de l'
Europe. L'ALENA a obtenu l'OMC, nous avons même eu  hyper
mondialisation avec la Chine, la Russie, l'Inde, la
zone de marché émergente sur les marchés mondiaux,
je ne me suis jamais inquiété de cette crise, celle du
faible profit racial et du public, la croissance
était élevée, je sais donc que cette crise,
je ne me suis jamais inquiété de la dette implicite et
j'ai financé celle provenant du vieillissement ou de
la population.  des jeunes travailleurs
et de leurs impôts qui financent les prestations
d'un plus petit nombre de personnes âgées aujourd'hui, c'est
le contraire.
Je ne me suis jamais inquiété de la dépression oui, il y a eu
des cycles économiques, certaines
récessions étaient légères dans les années 70 oui,
nous avons eu une stagflation mais a été suivie par
30 ans de  grande modération,
nous n'avons pas eu de très gros
boom de la crise financière, le crash du Bubble Buster, c'était la
régulation, la supervision des banques, le
contrôle des capitaux, la répression financière
et nous n'avions pas de levier toxique, la
financiarisation, les dérivés étaient aujourd'hui
économiques, les cycles étaient stables, le
cycle financier avec eux et finalement nous avons utilisé
vivre dans des démocraties libérales ouais, il y
avait des désaccords entre le centre droit et la gauche,
mais pas le genre de polarisation partisane extrême
l'année entre les
partis populistes extrêmes d'extrême droite ou de
gauche qui deviennent maintenant plus populaires en arrivant au
pouvoir, donc c'est le monde dans lequel je t'ai vécu
vite  avec impatience aujourd'hui, nous avons un risque de
guerre entre les puissances mondiales
et une guerre nucléaire, pas seulement une
guerre commerciale, le changement climatique, les catastrophes, les
pandémies se produisent plus fréquemment,
pourquoi il n'y en avait pas entre 1918 et
1980, maintenant nous avons le
VIH, le SIDA, les juments, le SRAS, la grippe porcine, la grippe aviaire.
zika Ebola covid-19 et ce n'est qu'une
question de temps car à mesure que nous détruisons l'
écosystème animal, les animaux
porteurs des agents pathogènes, les chauves-souris pangolins se
rapprochent du bétail et des humains, puis
la transmission zoonotique des
tumices animales est plus fréquente, donc elles seront
encore pires.  pandémie à l'avenir
maintenant avec le risque que l'IA détruise la plupart
des emplois augmentant l'égalité
permanente euh le chômage est
technologique nous avons la démondialisation
et le protectionnisme nous avons
des cycles économiques plus importants nous avons une dette privée et
publique une dette implicite explosive
provenant du vieillissement explosif et maintenant un
objectif autoritaire de  la droite et la gauche
arrivent au pouvoir donc ces 20 dernières années
j'ai montré l'émergence de ces
méga menaces qui n'existaient même pas dans
les 34èmes années d'or entre 1945 et
le début des années 80 point supplémentaire
la période avant 1945 vous aviez 30 ans
ils  On dirait qu'aujourd'hui,
malgré la première industrialisation,
malgré la première ère de
mondialisation, nous n'avons pas empêché la Première Guerre mondiale
et après la Première Guerre mondiale, nous avons eu la
grippe espagnole, puis avec le
krach boursier de 29, puis nous sommes au début
de  la Grande Dépression, puis nous avons eu l'
inflation,
l'hyperinflation, la déflation, les
guerres commerciales, les mots de monnaie, la
crise financière, cette crise, les défauts de
paiement, le chômage, l'effondrement économique de 25 pour cent,
puis
les nazis avec Hitler sont arrivés au pouvoir
en Allemagne, les fascistes avec Mussolini
peuvent prendre le pouvoir en Italie, Franco est arrivé au pouvoir
en Espagne et en  L'armée agressive
peut exercer son pouvoir au Japon, puis avec la
Seconde Guerre mondiale, puis avec l'Holocauste
et seulement après cela, nous avons créé les
institutions qui nous ont donné une
paix et une prospérité relatives pendant un certain
temps dans nos méga menaces,
aussi mauvaises que les 30 vilaines années.  années entre 1914
et 1945, où il y avait
quatre mégamenaces qui
n'existaient pas à l'époque et qui existent aujourd'hui, à cette époque,
vous n'aviez pas à vous soucier du
changement climatique, ce n'était pas un problème, il
ne s'inquiétait pas de la destruction d'emplois par l'IA,
il n'y avait pas  même un ordinateur, sans parler de
l'IA, vous n'aviez pas à vous soucier de la
dette implicite des gouvernements, car
les pensions du système de sécurité sociale avaient
à peine été créées et la plupart des gens
mouraient avant de recevoir leur
premier chèque de pension et étaient aussi laids que la
Première Guerre mondiale et la Guerre mondiale.  II était pour la
plupart des mots conventionnels, ce n'est qu'à
la fin de la Seconde Guerre mondiale, puis heureusement, ce sont
les États-Unis plutôt que l'Allemagne nazie qui ont obtenu
la bombe, puis les Américains ont utilisé la
bombe sur Hiroshima et Nagazaki pour arrêter
et mettre fin à la Seconde Guerre mondiale
cette fois-ci.  s'il y avait un conflit
entre grandes puissances, cette guerre ne
serait pas non conventionnelle, elle
commencerait conventionnelle, elle
deviendrait rapidement non conventionnelle, donc le
risque d'une guerre qui deviendrait un
hiver nucléaire pour l'ensemble des humanités est un nouveau
risque, donc par rapport au  Dans les années 30 et 40
aujourd'hui, les choses font l'objet de méga menaces,
elles n'existaient même pas dans ces
années 30, elles étaient laides et méchantes, nous ne pouvons donc pas
prendre les progrès pour acquis, nous ne pouvons pas
supposer que l'avenir sera
proche du passé, nous vivons comme des zombies, nous
sommes  Somnambule vers le désastre,
nous appuyons sur le bouton snooze, nous ne
résolvons pas ce problème, ils
s'aggravent de jour en jour, ils sont tous
interconnectés et à moins que nous ne
le changions, ce n'est pas seulement la fin de
nos revenus, de nos emplois ou de la sauvegarde de notre
santé.  la fin de la planète, la
fin de l'humanité pourrait entraîner la destruction de
notre propre espèce, c'est un risque auquel nous sommes
confrontés aujourd'hui. Je ne dis pas que cela va se
produire, mais nous devons être conscients du
problème et commencer à le résoudre individuellement et
collectivement. Niveau national  Au
niveau international et il est temps d'agir
maintenant, nous avons du temps perdu, le temps d'agir
est maintenant si nous ne le faisons pas, nous allons faire face à une
dystopie, à une instabilité, à un chaos et à un désastre,
c'est mon message principal
[Musique]
présumons
qu'une première est que
vous savez quand Covid  Cela arrive à
beaucoup de gens que je connaissais, même des amis se sont enfuis de
New York. J'habite à New York, ils sont allés à
Miami, ils sont allés dans les Hamptons, ils sont allés
dans le nord de l'État, j'ai passé
tout mon café littéralement tous
les jours à New York, je ne suis même jamais allé
une seule fois à Miami ou dans les Hamptons.  pendant trois
ans
jusqu'à ce que ça se termine
parce que vous savez, il y avait un confinement, j'aurais pu
tomber malade, j'aurais pu
finir à l'hôpital, j'aurais pu mourir
et puis il y a eu des manifestations
BLM à juste titre donc il y a eu même de la violence, il y a eu des
émeutes, il y a même eu des pillages
la plupart du temps.  les magasins de mon quartier
étaient fermés parce qu'ils
les pillaient et les cassaient, etc. Je
ne me suis pas échappé, vous devez faire face à la
réalité dans laquelle vous vous trouvez
s'il y avait
une autre pandémie mondiale, New York
en sera le point zéro.  parce que
la mondialisation, l'arrivée de beaucoup de gens,
bien sûr, était le point zéro, cela va se
reproduire
s'il y avait une guerre nucléaire, la première
arme nucléaire ira à New York, Washington,
Pékin et Moscou, tout le monde à New York
va mourir
euh le changement climatique augmente le
niveau de la mer  la majeure partie de Manhattan va
être sous l'eau. L'
ouragan Sandy a détruit une bonne partie
de Manhattan. Il y aura d'autres
ouragans, mais vous savez que vous ne pouvez pas vous
échapper dans une grotte. Dans le nord de l'État, vous ne pouvez pas
acheter un terrain en Nouvelle-Zélande en
espérant qu'ils l'éviteront.  ce gâchis
parce que ça va vous frapper d'une manière ou d'
une autre et si la plus grande partie de l'humanité est
détruite, vous voulez vivre.
Je préfère vivre ma vie à New
York en m'engageant socialement et politiquement
et en essayant de résoudre ce problème en espérant qu'ils
n'arrivent pas parce que  si cela
arrive, je préfère ne pas vivre, je préfère
mourir comme tout le monde plutôt que de fuir
ailleurs, donc la réalité est que
la façon de gérer ces choses est de
s'engager, d'en parler, d'
agir et de vivre sa vie.  tel quel,
plutôt que d'essayer de vivre dans un
pays des rêves où ce n'est pas un rêve, cela
va devenir un cauchemar et vous
ne pouvez pas échapper à la réalité et d'
ailleurs pendant la convoitise, car avant le café, je
passais la moitié de mon temps à faire le tour
du monde, je l'ai fait.  Je n'ai pas de temps pour mes
amis pendant la couverture, j'ai appris à cuisiner
et tous les vendredis soirs au dîner de Shabbat
et nous avons une conversation agréable
Jefferson où nous avons discuté d'un
sujet important avec une conversation commune
et tous les musiciens que vous faites, Kovid ne
pouvait pas jouer en live donc mon  la maison était à
quelques endroits avec de la musique live et des
séances de saut, nous avons donc créé, vous savez, un
dîner de Shabbat, une communauté, des âmes sœurs
et des amis qui survivent et
prospèrent pendant la convoitise, nous n'avons pas échappé à la
ville et nous créons une communauté donc le
côté positif de  Kovid était une meilleure
relation humaine, une meilleure amitié, un meilleur
sens de la communauté, moins de sentiment d'
anonymat, certaines personnes sont devenues plus
anonymes, plus seules.
J'ai créé la communauté de mes amis, donc même
au niveau personnel, c'est devenu une occasion
de grandir et de devenir plus
compatissant, plus attentionné et plus
conscient.
Musique]
euh
[Musique]
étrangère
Je ne suis pas toujours plus pessimiste en fait,
les deux événements majeurs de la dernière décennie
où j'étais beaucoup plus optimiste que le
consensus
en
2025 15 désolé 15 le consensus à Wall
Street était que le  Le Grexit aura lieu La
sortie de la Grèce de la zone euro
nous avons tous dit que Goldman Sachs City était leur
base de référence sur le Brexit J'ai passé plusieurs mois
à aller à Bruxelles Berlin Rome Athènes
Paris J'ai parlé à tous les décideurs politiques
et je me suis rendu compte de ce jeu de poule
entre la Grèce et la Troïka  La Grèce
n'avait pas une bonne main et elle devrait
cligner des yeux et j'ai réalisé que le
plan de sauvetage de la Grèce de 200 milliards de dollars était la
carotte en plus des bâtons de
réforme d'austérité qui les conduiraient à
rester dans la zone euro
et j'ai réalisé que
géopolitiquement  alors que le
ministre du Trésor de l'Allemagne
voulait probablement que la Grèce s'en aille, Angela America
s'est rendu compte que c'était l'année de la
crise syrienne et que les réfugiés, les différentes
cupidités avaient quitté la zone euro, alors tous
ces réfugiés viennent de Turquie en
Grèce vers l'Europe, donc c'était une
raison politique  pour le maintien de la Grèce dans la
zone euro et lorsque j'ai contacté tous ces
points, j'ai dit que le Grexit ne se produirait pas quand
tout le monde croyait que le Grexy se produirait
et qu'un effet dominant conduirait
le reste d'entre vous à l'effondrement. La
même chose s'est produite un an plus tard,
les gens étaient inquiets.  à Davos en janvier et
février 2016, l'atterrissage brutal de la
Chine a commencé en août le
15 septembre, puis la situation a empiré le
16 janvier et février. Le krach boursier à chaque
pensée, oh mon Dieu, le
marché chinois s'effondre, le marché boursier
américain s'effondre de plus de 20 pour cent.
répétition de la crise financière mondiale Un
atterrissage brutal de la Chine et tout le monde à
Davos me demandait si ce serait un
atterrissage brutal de la Chine une répétition de la
crise financière mondiale J'ai dit non, la Chine
n'aura pas d'atterrissage en douceur, elle n'aura pas  sur
un terrain dur, ça va
être cahoteux, ils ont les ressources pour
soutenir le système et essayer de contrôler
la crise, ce ne sera pas une autre
crise financière, donc sur les deux
événements majeurs de la dernière décennie où le
consensus était l'
effondrement de la zone euro et le Brexit.
effondrement de la Chine, nouvel
effondrement mondial. J'ai dit le contraire, c'était
beaucoup plus optimiste que le consensus. De
plus, lorsque je parle des
thèmes de mon livre aujourd'hui,
je ne parle pas d'extraterrestres venant de
Mars envahissant la Terre. Je ne
parle pas d'astéroïdes frappant la Terre.  la
planète
parle de menaces que tout le monde
reconnaît des centaines de livres sur le
changement climatique sur la dépression géopolitique sur
les pandémies sur les menaces financières sur la
démondialisation toutes ces choses sont
en fait assez évidentes ce qu'elles font à
valeur ajoutée Je relie les points
vous savez Je les appelle des méga menaces  d'autres
personnes l'appellent polycrise, le chef
du MF l'appelle Confluence de calamités
hier, leur femme a fait leur
rapport sur les risques mondiaux, même idée, connexion de toutes
ces différentes crises dont j'ai discuté,
donc les idées sont là, je relie les
points et je regarde d'un point de vue économique.
point de vue sur quels sont les coûts de
toutes ces méga menaces et comment chacun
de ces facteurs économiques affecte ces
méga menaces et comment elles sont connectées les
unes aux autres mais je ne parle pas de
science-fiction, ce n'est pas
du tout de la science-fiction  ce sont des menaces dont
tout le monde reconnaît l'existence, alors certaines personnes
disent que certaines sont plus risquées, d'autres moins
risquées, certaines vont se produire dans un
avenir lointain, certaines d'entre elles sont des
solutions politiques qui sont plus probables plutôt
que moins probables. Nous pouvons être d'accord ou
pas d'accord dans la mesure où  mais je
n'ai entendu personne dire qu'aucune de
ces méga-menaces n'existe, elles
existent toutes, la question est de savoir quelle est leur gravité
et pouvons-nous nous réveiller et pouvons-nous y
répondre avant qu'il ne soit trop tard, c'est
la seule question qui compte  du
débat
Elysium
[Musique]
euh, nous avons assisté au cours des dernières décennies à
une augmentation des inégalités de revenus et de richesse
au sein des nantis et non de
ceux qui avancent et de ceux qui sont
laissés pour compte, cela se produit dans les
économies avancées,
en particulier dans les anglo-saxons, mais cela se
produit  également en Chine, en Inde et dans
les marchés émergents et une partie des
réactions négatives contre la démocratie libérale vient
de cette augmentation des inégalités de revenus et de richesses,
c'est dangereux car lorsqu'il y a des
inégalités excessives, cela conduit à des
conflits sociaux, à la violence, à des guerres civiles,
parfois à la révolution ou à la montée des inégalités.
au pouvoir des populistes extrémistes de
droite et de gauche qui ne sont même pas
capables de réduire ces inégalités,
donc je pense que ces divisions sont
dangereuses et conduisent à terme à des
violences internes ou externes, donc à l'
augmentation des revenus et alors que les inégalités sont
l'une des menaces  que nous devons
résoudre
le malheureux problème est que généralement les
politiques de taxation des riches, de
redistribution aux pauvres ne
réduisent pas de manière significative les inégalités.
Historiquement, les inégalités n'ont été
réduites que lorsque vous avez les guerres de révolution, les
famines et la peste, mais c'est une situation dans
laquelle même les riches meurent ou sont victimes de la peste.  Être malade ou
perdre sa richesse n'est pas le meilleur moyen de
réduire les inégalités, donc la question que nous
devons nous poser est de savoir s'il existe des politiques
progressistes qui peuvent réduire les
inégalités avant que la violence ne réduise
les inégalités. Je ne suis pas sûr que nous ayons la
bonne réponse pour cet
étranger.
[Musique]  l'
évasion fiscale à elle seule n'est pas une menace majeure,
mais l'évasion fiscale l'évasion fiscale est l'une
des nombreuses raisons pour lesquelles les inégalités
augmentent.
parce que les élites ont un
pouvoir économique, politique et financier, elles changent
les réglementations, elles changent les lois fiscales
en leur faveur, le capital est plus mobile,
le travail et le capital peuvent se déplacer vers des
centres financiers offshore, ils ne
taxent pas correctement ou permettent à certaines sociétés, à
certains individus riches d'éviter le  les impôts
ou pour lutter contre l'évasion fiscale à tous les niveaux,
donc c'est un problème
étranger laïc
mais je pense que vous savez que
la Bible, en particulier l'Ancien Testament,
est toujours un excellent livre
euh, il y a beaucoup d'histoires en fait,
euh surtout dans la Genèse, sur l'
humanité, sur la tragédie, certaines  les gens disent beaucoup
de violence, d'inceste sexuel et d'autres
types de drames humains, mais il
y a aussi des valeurs morales et maintenant
vous créez une nation et maintenant vous créez une
meilleure humanité,
donc même une personne laïque, je pense, peut
trouver l'Ancien Testament comme  quelque chose qui vaut la peine d'
être lu
euh deuxièmement, vous savez, quand j'étais
jeune, je lisais beaucoup de littérature,
surtout au lycée, la grande
littérature européenne n'est pas seulement italienne ou allemande
mais même française
et tous les grands romans
de sauvegarde de la littérature française, c'était
vraiment tout  mon préféré était le
roman de Standal, en particulier Le Rouge
Lenoir, il y a une belle histoire, pas d'amour
et de passion, mais aussi de politique sociale et
de combinaison entre le personnel, le
social et le politique, c'est donc
un roman classique pour comprendre une
société, pas seulement des drames individuels.  donc
c'est fascinant et les nombreux autres
grands romans étaient définitivement celui-
là qui m'a touché
euh
je dirais que quand j'étais jeune avant de
vouloir devenir économiste j'étais
fasciné par la psychologie psychanalyse
et j'ai lu celui du premier  livres de
Sigmund Freud l'interprétation des
rêves
et chaque fois que je faisais ce rêve, je
l'écrivais et j'essayais de l'analyser
donc avant de devenir économiste, je
pensais que je deviendrais psychanalyste
et à partir de Freud j'ai commencé à lire les
livres et l'ouvrage  de l'
école alimentaire de Francfort comme ornamento
orenheimer marcuse et un mélange de
psychanalyse et de marxistes
et puis à partir de là je suis devenu un
pseudomarxiste probablement j'étais plutôt un
socialiste limousine mais ensuite de Marx j'ai
entendu parler de Keynes et je suis devenu un
économiste mainstream donc j'ai invité le
mainstream  l'économie via Sigmund Freud,
l'école de Francfort, Marcuse, puis
Marx
et puis à partir de là, j'ai atteint la
compréhension du système économique ou d'une
manière plus traditionnelle, donc
euh
génération
[Musique]
ouais, j'enseigne aux jeunes et ils me le disent
étant donné toutes ces méga menaces,
vous savez.  ce que je peux faire
euh et je dis que beaucoup de choses bien
sûr, faire face au changement climatique
nécessite des choix collectifs mais chacun de
nous fera de petits sacrifices
individuellement pour réduire nos
empreintes carbone, beaucoup d'entre eux ne sont pas faciles
mais nous pourrions donc nous ne pouvons pas simplement attendre
le gouvernement pour le faire, nous devons le faire
et nous devons également nous organiser
politiquement et socialement, les organisations
sociales, la société sinon le parti politique, donc
vous devez être engagé, vous pouvez résoudre
les choses individuellement, les deux premiers, vous devez
étudier et vous devez vous assurer
vous n'allez pas devenir obsolète
à cause de l'automatisation robotique de l'apprentissage automatique de l'IA. Je
dirais que vous devriez probablement vous spécialiser en
sciences souches, en ingénierie, en technologie mathématique, en
informatique, mais vous devriez également
avoir une mineure en arts libéraux, vous devez
penser de manière critique, lire tout en écrivant pendant
et  ce genre de compétences générales
vous permettra de changer d'emploi, car au cours de
votre vie, vous n'aurez jamais
toujours le même emploi dans le même secteur avec la même entreprise, comme c'était le
cas avant, vous étiez flexible,
agile pour changer.  emplois, donc une combinaison de
compréhension de la technologie et d'
esprit critique vous permettra à tous les
deux
de réussir et de prospérer plutôt que de
devenir obsolète, vous devez réaliser
que la vie est un marathon, ce n'est pas un
sprint,
vous devez étudier dur, des diplômes universitaires,
des diplômes d'études supérieures, réapprendre tous vos
recyclez-vous le temps, essayez d'être flexible,
apprenez à être curieux
et aussi dans vos décisions d'investissement
si vous faites du day trading si vous jouez avec des
crypto-actions Mimi Sparks, vous allez
perdre votre chemise,
vous devez investir et économiser tous les jours, cela
n'a pas d'importance pour vous  tu n'as pas assez de
revenus tu devrais épargner chaque année 15 de
tes revenus parce que ta Sécurité Sociale
ne sera pas là quand tu prendras ta retraite il y
aura trop de personnes âgées pas
assez de jeunes donc tu dois avoir un
manque supplémentaire d'épargne privée  vous
devez avoir un portefeuille diversifié
Actions mondiales américaines variété d'actifs
Matières premières nationales étrangères
et vous ne gagnerez pas cent pour
cent par an, personne ne gagne
huit à dix pour cent,
mais le principe des intérêts composés de
huit pour cent par an représente beaucoup d'
argent  sur le long terme
et si vous travaillez dur, étudiez l'art,
restez curieux, devenez intellectuellement curieux, vous
économisez, vous investissez dans un taux d'investissement,
pas dans la spécialité, avec le temps, vous réussirez, alors
pensez à la vie comme étant
un marathon plutôt qu'un sprint
et si  Si vous faites cela, vous survivrez probablement
et prospérerez malgré les méga
menaces, surtout si vous êtes engagé dans la
société avec votre système politique
pour créer un monde meilleur pour vous-même,
pour vos amis, pour votre famille, pour
vos enfants, pour vos semblables.
[Musique]
merci beaucoup de m'avoir reçu aujourd'hui,
ce fut un grand plaisir
[Musique] [
Musique]
merci
[Musique]